[Music]
you've never made a horror movie we
realize have you you mean never I I was
looking through all of your and I asked
for a reason because you seem like you'd
be a perfect person to like walk you
know like the innocent
thank you walk in you're you're very
pretty and wholesome and you look like
you'd be really good at like oh my god
there's a monster yeah you look like
prey is what he's saying yeah
your gunman victim thank you you're
welcome professional I never had a
cinematic release of a horror movie
but I have made one that I maybe didn't
bring up to you okay I'm just like one
of those straight-to-video kind of thing
great to video specifically at seven
words drive at my house in st. Louis
when I was 12 years old oh you made a
hole I made over a movie and it's scary
I don't know if you're easily frightened
but it's called the man under the stairs
we were on my younger sister carrying my
best friend Katie and I we were getting
some construction done on our house and
the stairs were exposed so we thought
let's put a man under there let's dress
up my younger sister Carrie as a man and
put her under those stairs your younger
sister was eight Wow yeah that's a scary
well I I wore all the hats I was the
director I was like the props master I
was like the line producer I was doing
everything but I was the only one who
actually wanted to be an actress at that
time and I'm the worst by up by far of
all three of them like I'm getting it
too much - right right right do you have
somebody
my producer in the course will break
said that you brought this is what you
brought video I have not seen this okay
do I don't know anything so this is
you're the victim I'm that yeah this is
uh this is now the world premiere of man
under the stairs
oh man under the stairs whoa
Hickey and okay this is when you're how
old
twelve years old and Kari was eight okay
let's take a look at the man
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what I love my favorite part is
you can clearly tell that you're trying
to step close enough so that your sister
can grab your foot in in York you can
see like no a little more to the side
and then they [ __ ] you barely gets your
ankle
I realize halfway I'm like oh no I'm Way
too far over and the only gag of this
movies that she grabs my leg and so yes
I'm also wearing moccasins I was in a
very earth-saving phase at that point I
was wearing moccasins and my shirt I
remember that shirt it was like every
day is Earth Day
yeah man you saw I was giving it way too
much yeah
there was no restraint you know the real
horror of that was a bunch of children
playing around exposed insulation that
was that that was the part that had me
scared
what's this dust oh well it'll be fine
you